so wir sind quasi in baden württemberg
hier im backstage bei im green room des
bundesvision song contests und haben
bakkushan aus baden württemberg ist das
richtig seid ihr aus baden betretet für
die bundesländer an aber es ist ja nicht
immer so dass alle aus dem bundesland
kommen wie sie bei euch ja aber es ist
tatsächlich so also ich bin in
heidelberg geboren direct mannheim daher
aus karlsruhe mannheim dazwischen genau
und grundsätzlich haben wir uns auch in
mannheim gegründet und kennengelernt
tatsächlich und waren da sehr sehr lange
also fünf jahre waren wir da schon und
deswegen ist das total zurecht ihr fühlt
euch als also heimisch und
wie seid ihr habt eine rockigere oder
sie würde jetzt nennen
es ist schon häufig auf jeden fall so
warum glauben sie
wie soll ich es formulieren es ist
manchmal schwierig zu formulieren
sondern ich frei heraus sagen nein
glaubt ihr mit sowas landen zu können
also ist ja immer die frage
was ist so der musikgeschmack im moment
was ist populär was nicht rechnet ihr
euch das chancen aus also ist rock
angesagt
es gibt auf jeden fall genug leute die
das hören ja es ist auch kein classic
rock oder irgendwo hat also es ist schon
auch irgendwie alternativ indierock was
bisschen frischer ist und ich glaube so
ansonsten auch viele teilnehmer dabei
die eher was so softes balladeskes spiel
und so und da ist ein rock stück
zwischendurch gar nicht so schlecht
glaube ich und ich glaube darauf gelegt
hatte ja wobei ich würde mal sagen wir
sind eine rockband wir können jetzt also
wenn wenn wenn wenn wir jetzt wir haben
hier nicht den plan hier abräumen zu
wollen und jetzt lasst uns mal rock
machen so also frage ist ansich unsinnig
weil man würde als gruppe ja nie sagen
man würde ja nie sagen wir nehmen am
bundesvision song contest teil was
machen wir jetzt nein aber trotzdem ich
muss doch irgendwas fragen leute
wie kommt es dann dass so eine gruppe
wie ihr für baden württemberg antritt
sagte der ministerpräsident
also das muss was rockiges seien für
baden württemberg ja ich glaube
wir haben da auch einen guten draht ins
ministerium und alles möglich also
häufig sehen die prognosen bei euch was
auch das management
irgendwo zwischen 1 und 16
ich frage nichts mehr ich frage euch die
prognosen keine ahnung also wie sagt
dabei seien super geil und wir haben
total bock auf ihr auf eine platzierung
im einstelligen bereich
dann drücke ich die daumen und achtung
alle hier gucken also auch hierfür
bakkushan aus baden württemberg wenn er
findet samstag für dieses video
favorisieren und ruft natürlich an um
guckt das video so oft wie es geht was
möchtet ihr denn wünscht ihr euch von
den youtube zuschauern ja was er schon
gesagt hat schaut euch das video an und
falls ihr bock habt könnt ihr auch auf
unserer homepage www bakkushan de weil
wir kommen uns direkt war sie auf tour
im oktober sind wir unterwegs sein
können reinschauen und live ist das
ganze noch nun um
das ganze im info text unter dem video